debbie is in columbus ohio hi debbie
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call
my honor how can we help i just got done
paying
hundred and 31 six dollars um in debt
i am a single female um i'm currently
living in an apartment
way to go and i have started
way to go thank you
i i currently have one thousand four
hundred and ten dollars in my money
market account
and i've been working with an
accountability buddy
to help keep me on budget he got me to
help me get a budget
and um now he wants me to i'm working on
baby step three
it should take me to the end of the end
of 2022
to get 12 000 into my money market
account
and he said he also wants me to start
saving up for a house for a 20
down payment on a condo and he said he
wants me to put the money in a roth ira
so it can get a little more interest
than a money market
and then he said as soon as you have a
20
down payment for your condo i want you
to pull your money out of your
roth ira plus whatever else i had saved
up
and we're going to put that on a condo
and i i would be buying this on my own
um i know you you want people to do fix
15-year fix but i'm 55.
i just turned 55 and i don't want 1200
dollar
mortgage payments in my 70s
and i told him that and he said well
maybe we need to go to a 30-year
mortgage
so you can get smaller payments and then
i said i could just treat that like a
debt snowball
in baby step two so if i my current
rent is 844 dollars which is 25 percent
of my take-home pay
because you said don't get a mortgage
greater than 25 percent of your
take-home pay
so that would mean i would need a
mortgage right around eight hundred and
fifty dollars
well your mentor is telling your mentor
is telling you a lot of the same things
we tell you but he's
telling you a few things different than
we tell you right
i need to know your way what is the best
way
or the wisest way to do this what do you
make you're making
forty thousand dollars a year uh 67
308. when do you plan on retiring
70 72 71 somewhere in there
okay all right uh before dave comes back
in to give you some more
some more wisdom because he could
definitely help out with this this age
bracket
one of the things i i don't like that
your uh
mentor is telling you to park the money
in a roth ira
that's a bad move um i would i could i
could definitely see you parking that
into like a mutual fund like an s p
500 um if it's going to be about three
to five years and that's a great route
but if you put in time if you put it
inside a retirement account you're gonna
pay interest and penalties
uh not interest you're gonna pay
penalties um and so i i don't want that
to happen
uh so that's the very first thing and
then for me i could be in here and dave
please quit me if i'm wrong but i'm at
this age bracket i'm not in a rush to
like do you
have to move into a home like do you i
don't need to move in
um he just said you're paying 850
dollars a month in rent right now and he
said rent is only going to go
up but debbie you're 70. i agree i agree
that it's going to go up and i don't
want you i do want you to get in the
home ownership position
because it'll stabilize your budgeting
as you go into retirement but i would
not do more than a 15-year fixed
i think you can do better than end of
2022 to finish your emergency fund that
sounds
like that's taking too long to me
definitely don't use a roth completely
agree with anthony on that
use a roth for your retirement savings
but not for your saving up for a house
and no we don't do a 30 we do a 15.
because you don't want a 30 you'll pay
off in 30 years you know what 15 will
pay off in 15 years
and and you're going to do it you're
going to be okay you're going to select
a home that fits that
and you don't have to put down a full 20
to purchase
it just saves you pmi if you do it saves
your private mortgage
insurance if you do so what i would do
is finish this emergency fund faster
i would not use a roth i would do a
15-year fixed where the payments no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay
but i think you've got some other stuff
coming out of this check that you're not
counting here
take home pay when we say a fourth of
your take-home pay we don't mean
after health insurance after retirement
or after payments you're paying out of
your check
we mean after taxes yeah and 67
000 should be bringing home more than
you're bringing home
oh just after taxes so you got something
else coming out of your check there
or you're getting a big refund and
you're going to need to adjust your w-4s
and get your refund down to where it's
zero you don't want to be getting a big
refund every year
so um you should be getting home with
more
cash than you're getting home with
unless you've got it going to health
insurance or something inside your
your check there but take-home pay is
not
um uh it is only only means
after taxes not after everything else so
i think you're gonna be able to afford a
house a little condo like you're talking
about get it on a fixed rate
a 15-year and um you know
you do not want to go into retirement
the ending the end
of your life with a bunch of debt still
on a house because you took out a 30
and hoped you were gonna snowball it no
just don't buy it if you can't put it on
a 15.
yeah but i think you can and i think
you'll be able to figure it out
good call and you're doing really good
great
she knows her numbers she does she knows
exactly where she is she does
she does now dave let me ask you this
question though because uh it's a
learning experience for me
when i hear someone of that age and
educate me and tell me where i'm wrong
get in my thinking
i get a little nervous to tell my
grandmother to go to go buy a home
you know what i'm saying like because
there's so much more responsibilities
than just the mortgage payment
that comes with that well a condo i mean
a condo doesn't have the exterior
maintenance you're absolutely right you
have the interior maintenance and stuff
here's the problem the number the
largest item in your personal budget the
typical person's personal budget is
their mortgage payment
true and it's a rent payment and it's if
it's a rent payment it's going to go up
every year if it's mortgage payment it's
not it's going to stay flat
and when you can get it paid off yes you
got
rid of the biggest item in your budget
in your last years
yeah and you've stabilized
you're destabilized when you're a renter
because you're at other people's house
yes and they can do all kinds of stuff
like make you move and everything else
and so
but you've stabilized your life by
owning
okay and by fixing the payment and or by
getting it paid off completely it's even
more stabilized makes sense
so it's a stabilizing factor for your
uh last 20 years of life you know
whatever that is if you go say from
uh you know 70 to 90 or something like
that that kind of a thing now you know
the older you are the more you think
okay
but um you know my grandpa used to say
i'm not buying green bananas you know so
uh you know you you do start to think
about what you're purchasing and so
forth but
um coleman and i took a call the other
day from a
lady said she was gonna sell her land to
her 85 year old uncle
and i'm like why is he buying land you
know it's just but but
but it's okay i just you know what what
is the thought process behind that in
his case he had a good thought process
but but um
it's the same reason we teach people
with the baby steps millionaire the
everyday millionaires to
people doing the baby steps to become
millionaires they become everyday
millionaires
to get their home paid off because
that's one of the bigger elements of
wealth building
yes as well that's one of the two things
that most of the millionaires have done
they've got their home paid off okay
and uh so it's still all parlays in
there together but
but uh you know if you're 92 it makes no
sense you know maybe not
yeah you know i you know i hope you
lived 107 right but
um but the statistical averages are not
in your favor at that point so no i
probably wouldn't go by then
but she's only 55. i mean that she's got
life expectancy of uh 30 years at this
point
so average death age of a female in
america right now 74 of a male
72 but that includes infant mortality
and teenage death
and so when you make it healthy into
your 50 late 50s early 60s you've got a
very high statistical likelihood of
making it into your 90s
very high and so that i mean that's
just because that's the way the averages
work out yeah so it's good questions
good discussion